Let's do the first one at so it says
calculate the probability of each of the following events the event
where we have at most three lines in
use.
Okay, what is the probability that at most three lines are
in use so let's let's do this together now.
I'm going to come to box map.
Let's begin with question one.
question one
and let's think about what it's asking us to do.
This will be mathematical rotation.
So P of what P of?
P of x
less than or equal to 3 it says at most
like the limit is 3
at most 3, so we are going to accumulate the
probability from 0 to 3.
So in other words we are we are saying what is the probability
that X less than equal to 3?
Like count up like count up to the probability distribution
of the random variable what it is at Value 3.
so
we're asking if x equals to 0.
or
x equals 1 or x equals 2
or x equals
yeah, so we also have to include the probability when no lines are in use
because it it's asking us at most three
lines.
It's not saying at least one and up at
most three. It's at most three so we have to add up all of the probability.
So that means we have to count.
the probability of 0
and 1 and 2 and
you know up to three.
one
plus two
plus three
plus 4
y 4 that's a mistake. Sorry.
and so let's
plug in the numbers
so this is the number of
telephone lines that I use
so they have six telephone lines here. We
ask you like for example here when we look at six we're asking
what is the probability that all six all six
will be in use
That's 4%
Yeah, exactly. Yeah, I guess see that that's
the thing with textbooks sometimes even
the question.
Gets in the way of you figuring out the problem. You don't even know what
the question is saying. I agree maybe this the the question could
be phrased better. The question could be phrased. But
yes, thank you Matt. Yeah X is the sum of the lines.
So is one line is used zero lines is used
what one like one person's on the phone two people
on the phone three people on the phone and so on.
And here the first question asked what is
it? Probably that at most three people on the phone like four three employees are
underlying talking to customers. For example.
And what we do to answer this question is we add up the
numbers.
So we add up point 10 point 15 Point 20
and point twenty five.
Point ten point fifteen Point twenty Point twenty five
so point 10
sorry point 10 point 15.
point
I'll come back to comment and
there's a second Point ten point 15 Point 20 point.
and if you add this up, so that's 25 plus 40.
So that's 0.65.
now Anders says
Maybe it's clear if you don't use capital X in
the introduction to the variable.
In the introduction to the variable.
That I make a mistake 0.7.
Point seven, sorry.
And there's what did you mean by?
introduction to the variable
if you can clarify that question for me.
But let's see.
But I'm going to assume you're asking to
use a different character to denote the random variable. But
the thing is the convention in statistics is to use.
Yes, yes. Okay. So I'm I'm gonna answer Andrew's question
by answering Dexter's question. Yes, there is a there's a difference
between
capital x and a sample X
the entire table that you're looking at this entire thing.
Okay.
At least the first column.
random variable X
corresponds to the entire
I know I say Colin, but I guess here it's a roll.
Okay, but if you put it turn this around it'll be a column anyway.
the random Bible corresponds to all of these X
values
okay X is this
I don't want to use the word set because set means something
specific in mathematics, but it is the thing containing all of these small
Nexus. So all of these small X's go into the BX.
The other problem with the word random variable is
it's not a valuable because when we think about
the variable we think about a small letter.
that is
as that has to assign a specific number.
You see the person who called.
This thing random variable was called mokorov Russian.
He's up.
person who made big contributions to the field of
probability Theory
But by there by death of the mathematical definition is
that it's really a function. It's really
a function. It Maps a domain to
a code domain. So for example, you would say
What is the seat for example
you'll pass a seat number to the random variable and it will tell
you whether it's it's a side or not a sign that's effectively a
function.
So when you look at when you hear about the random variable X and you
see it in writing.
Try to identify it as a function not as a
numeric not as a valuable that corresponds to
a number.
Okay Dexter.
And I hope Anderson also answers your question as
to why we use a big X. It's important.
It's a there's a reason why it's upper X.
now if in the text X has
already been assigned that's when we move on to y and z
this is true also for
small X if small X has been assigned to a value and
you have to choose another random value would go with YNC.
This is the convention mathematics. If you have constants, he used
the first letters in the alphabet. So a b and c would be constants xyzing
variables.
Okay.
let's quickly do the answer for question two, and
then we move on to the next to the next topic which is
which is
the moment
and then we can we'll start to wrap up
the wrap up this the moment by the way.
The moment is a pivotal.
point in our Learning Journey here
But let's quickly answer this question. So we really like understand the probability
notation and the random variable notation the
probability distribution notation.
so question to ask
question two
asks
At least three lines are in use. What does that mean at least three meaning three
or more?
three or more
so I'm just going to borrow.
The solution here to complete the
solution for this exercise.
This would be
probability that X
will be greater than or equal to 3.
Now in some text actually.
Always stick to less than equal sign. So the position
of 3 and X would change but that's not important right now.
The idea is
What is the probability that three or more telephone lines will
be?
active
so we probably have three.
probability of
the random value random variable when it is at
three, that's such a mouthful.
But I'm trying to be precise with my words what to
do.
and then P equals 4
If someone can quickly add up the numbers, I would appreciate
it because I don't have the solution to this exercise. I'm solving it
with you.
and
three four five or six
three four
five or
six
But you know that's you just have to add up the numbers. It's quite
simple three four five or six. So three
is
Point 25
and then
0.244
and
point
six four five
and point four
four six
Yeah, sorry.
45 plus 10
Okay. Yes. So for example you could
use this.
We haven't even made it to.
The other topic since but just this.
The ideas that we've looked at so far namely probability the
mass function and the cumulative distribution function.
would allow you to for example gain insight into your
let's say your business.
or any activity
That you're taking.
So for example, you can see that.
You're more likely to have.
or the probability of having
three lines or up to three lines is higher than
having three or more lines.
And maybe you can use that to influence your business decision.
now it doesn't warrant us to
graph this probability distribution because
it's such a small data set.
But nonetheless once we do get it get into bigger data
sets.
It will be this the random variable in the probability distribution
that will allow us to get to
You know graphs and charts and that kind of thing.